hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the most unlikely collab
that i ever saw
bridge constructor the walking dead
because if there's one thing that
walking dead can't deal with
it's bridges also this video is
sponsored by the epic game store if you
want to play this game for yourself and
build stupid bridges that are going to
be stupider than my bridges
you can click in the link in the
description below and also use my
creator tag markiplier
in the epic game store whenever you make
purchases like buying
ridge constructor to support me so
anyway uh this one unfortunately
well actually no i'm gonna say very
fortunately does not have a multiplayer
portion where you guys can suggest
anything
stupid for me to build i have to rely on
my own stupidity
to build the things that i need to build
the world came to an end
and we didn't even realize it oh
oh i'm supposed to click yes
people got sick and died
i think people might realize that then
started coming back
people would definitely realize that the
pundits on cable news
said it was all a hoax a month later
they were dead too those few of us who
survived were terrified and lost
scavenging the remains of a world that
had all but disappeared overnight
do you guys notice the zombies down
there so yeah if you know the bridge
constructor games
uh this is where i build a bridge and i
think i'm supposed to build a bridge
that does not lead zombies across the
gap because that would be
counter-intuitive
it was just another day in the end times
no tv no internet no warm water no clean
sheets and no food
let's not bother with that street again
nothing left to scavenge just dead me
walking we might still be able to find
some meds in doc boyle's old office
and exactly what kind of medication are
you hoping to get from a proctologist's
office mild man
a lot of lube pardon me for interrupting
the prostate banter
but i currently find myself in a
perilous situation and eminentism
assistance
hold it fella what the heck are you
thinking sneaking up on us like that
eugene's a name but before we commence
with a lengthy
i have to cut to the chase the living
dead are on my heels and i strongly urge
you to ready your firearms
i'm afraid we're fresh out of guns ain't
no shame in hiding though get in that
ditch i'll build this a shelter
and keep quiet mullet head you've caused
us enough trouble as it is
roger that i shall provide a helping
hand all the while keeping quiet as a
church mouse on sunday
man this guy's annoying you'll need to
build a bridge to get the approaching
walkers over the ditch and keep a party
safe
oh i do need to get the zombies on the
other oh
before you start remove the existing
wood elements okay
right follow the instructions okay
okay all right
convert okay cool now let the walkers
come and pray the stability of those
wooden planks
oh okay all right
i get it i get it so this is kind of
like the portal bridge constructor game
that i played that i liked a lot all
right good for us
those things are as dumb as they are
dead i'm kyra by the way i'm miles and
you son would be pretty practical
companion without that runaway mouth of
yours
my appreciation for the law dash law
that law
daddy oh my capabilities are more
inclined toward the theoretical but from
time to time they do prove useful
god why did we have to have a neckbeard
survive the apocalypse
oh my god a person from the subreddit i
am very smart just happened to grace us
with our presence how you folks feeling
about dinner all we've got is some sugar
in the mold that's growing on it
maybe we can find something to eat in
this warehouse not to denigrate your
otherwise reasonable suggested course of
action
but have you factored in the danger
posed by the that pack of undead
approaching from the loading area
eugene could you shut up could you shut
up eugene
could you shut up the physical
attributes of that cylindrical oh
my god i hate you eugene
the way you speak is just the worst
you want to crush the walkers with a
cable spool crush eradicate whatever
let's move on i'm starving
okay use the cable fool from the upper
floors okay
you'll need to build a ramp okay
got it okay
no
there we go go then i guess
well that did it i'm great now that
we're loaded up
with all this pre-packaged preserved
snacky goodness i gotta say
that was awesome but it was also really
loud
i prefer the physics-based solution
guaranteed to eliminate our advertisers
i did not promise against any sonic
repercussions
eugene i will throw you off a bridge if
you keep talking like that
our supplies were taken care of but the
dead were closing in we could only hope
our new friend could come up with
another crafty solution
those fellas look 100 dead and none too
friendly how the hell did we get past
him
i say we do what we just did again but
better
i'm gonna translate him into in a normal
speech hey look up there it's a big old
box
so someone needs to run and release a
container and crush those walkers i
don't envy whoever draws the short straw
on that one
why are you guys looking at me like that
don't be afraid we got a big old play
he'll be good they'll all be dead and
you'll survive
no problems you trust me all right this
is a tactical level it contains
waypoints where you can give your heroes
commands for what to do where they go
next and what they
do when they get there oh interesting in
this case you want to instruct miles to
control panel and release
oh oh well this is nifty
oh i like oh come all
oh interesting
okay interesting okay so
cogwheel so we want this guy to go there
cogwheel and then go down
go down okay cogwheel and then down oh
interesting select this waypoint okay
now go to the right i love it i actually
do love that
that's super cool that's very cool
i like that a lot
all right that is super cool can we go
is he gonna die he better not i probably
didn't need all that much reinforcement
but
i felt like it so pushed a button
bam dead and then
finish easy that looks fun
it hit him real good it hit him quick
and they dead
fast i think eugene is much more
palatable now things were getting hairy
and our death from above plan was hardly
risk-free
miles was not pleased good things come
in threes what do you say we try this
plan again maybe give it a little more
kick
miles steer them over there and we'll
crush them i've had it with this plan
i'm too damn old to keep playing the
cheese in your mouse trap
relax i'll suck it up and be the bait
this time get ready for some shock and
awe y'all
oh thank goodness eugene wasn't talking
in the mission where there's more than
one hero involved you can switch between
heroes each one has their
own set of commands for each waypoint
each hero's waypoint is assigned its own
color to help you tell them apart for
example kyra's of color is always yellow
make sure that the correct waypoint and
hero selected when assigning your
commands
for additional guidance to survive to
the brit in the bridge constructor the
walking dead universe
check out the constructor's guide in the
apocalypse to the apocalypse in the
level menu
the what ah
i see i know all this i'm great at this
game i beat all the portal one i should
be fine
all right what was i supposed to do okay
walkers need to die
or be crushed ah i see i see i see
so you're gonna go there you're gonna go
up and then you're gonna go
no you're gonna go up and then you're
gonna go right and then
this dude he's gonna go
to here and he's gonna go use it and
then he's gonna go
left back to a and then
maybe he maybe we need to buy a little
bit more time
you know what i mean maybe instead of
that we go left
no he can't it would be impossible he
can't come back from that
okay so we just gotta build right you
know what i mean
okay well we can do that
we can definitely do that we basically
just need to destroy that
that thing
you know what i mean so that should be
able to roll down there
and then this provides good support here
oh that's probably good enough i don't
know all i need to do is have someone
walk over it so
that'll go there and that'll smash and
it should be fine
oh that was quick on the button those
quick on the button and then kaboom
easy easy peasy then up i'm a genius
i'm a genius i'm a genius i am so smart
you've got a lot of nerves sending me
over that rickety-ass bridge
what oh i'm sorry but you's gonna be all
right all the time
because of what we did you had to be a
little bit in danger
oh my god look i ain't good at math but
you probably have good chances if not
die
hear that kyra hi 80s how can you stay
mad after he gave us
his word anyway at least we can move on
from this particular death trap now
there must be an exit around here
somewhere
yeah now that you guys are in completely
other side of the moon of the room
we weren't out of the woods yet this
warehouse was amazing every step
threatened to be our last
all this noise is like a maiden call for
those bastards they're swarming the
halls
it would be much worse situation if
zombies mated i've told you 100 times
the warehouse is full of yummy stuff and
not so yummy walkers
let's move out smarty pants back me up
here look this seems dangerous let's
just get the freak out of here
i'm gonna put down some wood and then i
can get across this big old hole and
then i'll be able to
get the ladder all right so i made a
screaming machine
it's going to draw all the zombies it
screams real loud it's me screaming into
a box and then the box screams back
i don't know how it works but it'll get
their attention you ever had a milkshake
you know how they got cherries on them
oh those cherries are good cherries are
good
yeah but imagine if the cherry was also
death on top of the milkshake
and then you know ah real heavy cherry
and this slams down you think you're
gonna get a milkshake you get a big old
box on your head that's what's gonna
happen to the zombies
all right i guess it's just this guy now
oh no if he dies
what will we do another chance to crush
some walkers under a giant container
unfortunately they're not currently in a
good position for crushing luckily some
characters have exclusive additional
commands that they can execute at
waypoints
eugene's special command is to throw a
speaking doll that attracts nearby
walkers for the duration of the mission
next to eugene's portrait you'll find a
number of dolls available for this
mission
great all right i get it i get it i get
it you know i
you could just let me figure things out
you know
okay then you're gonna throw a doll you
can adjust the jaw's trajectory
ah oh oh
right there perfect done
and then you're gonna go
up and then you're gonna go here
activate
go down then you're gonna
go down up
it is a puzzle that's a pretty good
puzzle
okay that should do it let's see if i
get eugene killed
probably ah no he's fine
i probably don't even need to make that
much stuff for just a dude oh my god
what is that thing
there's a horrible monster hey look at
that
wow that's pretty good oh i over
built oh stop stop right there go back
no no no no no go stop okay so i
definitely didn't need to build as much
as i did
so let's do mini bridge
mini bridge mini bridge all right go
that'll hold no eugene no
his ankles oh no so mini bridge
apparently didn't work i don't know why
seems kind of stupid you know
there we go now mini bridge will succeed
damn it you are my one true friend in
this dark
age of death with only eugene to comfort
me
there we go i don't really see how
that's saving a lot more uh
wood than the last version of it but
whatever it's all within the
necessary constraints oh eugene i mean
yay
eugene made it yay good i'm glad
hey why you guys not leave i mean i
don't know the way out of the city
because i don't know left from right but
why haven't you guys like gone
most of my friends already abandoned me
the first day that they meet me
miles ain't good with the change in
general took me long enough to get him
out of the basement where he was hiding
nothing good ever came have changed
world was a-okay before this
okay i did it um the best we kept
turning walkers into pig feed the one
good thing since eugene came along
but there was still no end to this
complex and we were wondering if we'd
ever see the daylight again
how are you stuck in a warehouse for
this long i get it eugene it's a proven
plan but i don't like the way the
container's tipping over
well if you run you probably not gonna
die
that's all i know i just run i like
running hey but also when you run
you should probably run real fast okay
okay cool your fun guy miles if i don't
make it shove and mull it first into the
next gang of wankers okay
yeah that sounds good i'm glad they all
hate this guy
all right so what i gotta do i know i
know i'm gonna build a way to detach me
i get it i get it i get it i know what's
up
here
what's my requirement really got that
little wood
all right well i guess i i don't need i
don't need all the structure
to do this if i have um this here so
i'm pretty sure that can go then i'll
just adjust this a bit more straight on
there we go i'm under the level required
this is probably going to be fine
it's not heavy enough it's not it's
heavy enough it's heavy enough
nice nice nice i did it
i did it perfect that was a little too
close for comfort eugene but i guess
i'll let i'll think about letting you
live
enough bickering children this way great
what have you found now another hall
full of walkers complete with containers
ready to tip over and pulverize us
even better on exit oh good
i didn't know you were that stuck in
here also how are you guys
building these bridges so quickly i see
a van down the hill
reckon to make a good ride what are we
gonna do about those walkers though
can we please for once come up with a
plan that won't mangle us to bits if we
make a tiny mistake
hey uh my uncle once told me that you
know
he put a knife in his hand and it was
like a double blade thing he was like
perfectly balanced as all good things
should be he was a big purple guy i
don't know weird
it runs in the family i suppose anyway
that stuck with me does that help
anybody no i think that's eugene for
let's get a move on we got a new
material to work with cable look it's
good for lightweight connections over
longer distance
careful though it can't support joints
from the bottom another note there's no
construction point to the right hand
side of the gap to fully attach your
bridge try ending the bridge somewhere
near the ledge
heroes can climb or hop over little gaps
oh heroes these guys heroes
are you sure about that okay so we've
got something here
and i'm guessing that the the thing
about this is
uh is that thing won't uh
won't exactly support uh the weight
will it i don't know what exactly
qualifies as like a short gap
yeah but i'm guessing this thing is
gonna fall
if we do it too stupidly
which i'm guessing is uh the majority of
my ability to do things
oh i see what it wants me to do
it wants me to counterweight this thing
so that it won't tippy tip over here
so i gotta make the most leveraged
counterweight possible
okay and then for good measure maybe
one of these in a cable
no no no no
no come on no
way it'll probably work jump it
you idiots you idiot you
you idiots you thought you could jump
gaps
so jump it oh my god oh my god i swear
oh my
okay all right that guy made it okay
good it was great you guys are so
good at your everything you guys are so
good
okay there we go you were fine the whole
time
you were 100 fine you just could you
said you could hop
over a gap and he fell funny how people
just leave their keys in the car
very convenient less stock more ignition
chop chop here goes
a gas tank must be empty nothing we can
do about that here maybe we should ask
the dude on the motorcycle if he knows
where to find some
fuel what dude what motorcycle i haven't
seen anyone yeah there's a big surprise
let's get a move on
i'm sure we can find gas somewhere
there's a rest area off the interstate
just up this roadways
used to service all the buses taking
taking folks up and down the coast maybe
we can score some gas
ah the bus enthusiast hey you like
buses man i love buses i used to come
here every weekend to see the buses
i would just ride them up and down i
love buses no idea how they work
oh boy man then there was that bus crash
and ah
everyone's dead i guess
still love buses though still love them
hey look up there
there's a guy it's a new friend let's go
make a new friend
what are we waiting for i don't know
what are we waiting for
hey new friend heroes can actually kill
a few enemies with melee attacks but
this requires stamina
if their stamina fully depletes during a
fight they'll be overwhelmed by the
enemy that stranger looks tough he
shouldn't have a problem eliminating the
few walkers ahead of him
the large group on the floor needs a
different approach
i see i see
so what you're saying is
guy goes this way and then he goes up
and in a circus pattern can this be
pulled down
is that what i'm is that what i'm
hearing is that what i'm understanding
this this thing can probably be pulled
down okay
so no matter what this guy's got to get
across whatever this guy's name is
whatever ralph i think it was steve
i don't know what this asshole's
supposed to do you're gonna throw uh
this
somehow i guess oh interesting
that is an option no but there's a wall
there
what would be the point of that uh i
know exactly what good that would do
i see what you got going on here because
when they push that it's gonna knock
this
over and right on top of them i see
what's got going on here
i see what's got going on i
see what i see what's got going on
oh god i forgot about oh god
and he's not so good okay okay never
mind
something went horribly wrong okay so
yeah uh maybe the throw
could be a little more arced and not so
stupid
because that was a pretty stupid throw
i'm not gonna lie that that throw was
dumb
yeah yeah yeah okay all right
now we're gonna try okay never mind oh
no he's
not okay so anyway
about that
there we go okay can you not
keep why do you choose to do that
why do you choose to leap this gap it's
not a gap
what are you doing i'm going for it
oh jesus what is wrong with you it's
just
is this really too complicated for you
all right how about that
nope yep maybe oh my god
oh my god i hate you i hate you sir
there we go don't you go my god this
this guy is just
incapable can you please
there we go there we go
get him yeah there you go
easy easy peasy okay get up from that
good
oh okay all right good good job there
pal
i get it i know what it i i'm a genius
instead of going there you're gonna go
up and then you're gonna go
right across the same bridge and you're
gonna take a swan
dive off of there and it's gonna be just
fine
yep let's see how this does i don't know
if he's gonna make this dive
okay and then he's gonna go back up and
he's this is gonna be fine he's gonna be
fine he's gonna be fine
he's gonna be fine oh he's gonna be fine
he's gonna be fine
he's gonna be fine he's gonna be good
he's gonna be fine he's gonna be fine
maybe not fine okay so i i know now what
it wants me to do easy
then he just drops down slam
easy easy
bam hey hey
oh god no
no jerry jerry
oh all right how about that is that
going to be out of the way
there you go this is going to work this
is fine
and then easy it is interesting with all
the mechanics of like
the different waypoints and commands
like that and then trying to understand
exactly
how things go there we go easy peasy
nice i'm good and now we got
todd
daryl that was it thanks for the help
thought i was gone her name's daryl glad
to help you boys reunite but now we
gotta get out of here
reckon we could get one of these
vehicles over there running i think
we're gonna be good friends
i think we're gonna be real good friends
i can't wait to share
everything about my life with every one
of you everything
okay good we're all friends we're all
family
we're all one big beautiful family
create passage for oh that was chapter
one done okay cool
now i can actually get into it oh we're
driving now
finally felt good to be on the road
again we had no destination just
somewhere safe so as soon as we
hit our first major problem the bridge
ahead of us was collapsed
hey listen i might be dumb
well i got a funny feeling about this
bridge i think we can drive right over
it
yeah everyone relax bridges may have
collapsed but i'm sure we can build
something to get across
that construction site we passed a while
back had some steel girders that might
come in handy
i ever told you guys how much i like
stars
i got a lucky star up there you guys
know stars
have you seen stars they're great
wow i love stars let's get on with it
already
all right you got it it's heavier yeah i
know steel i get steel all right okay so
what we're gonna need to do is we're
gonna need to build a very nice
gently inclining gently inclining
and stable build how much do they use i
mean we could probably do this out of
wood i bet
i bet oh but you can't make wood as long
that doesn't matter does it
no it doesn't matter screw that and
screw you
was that any less than the steel wait a
minute how much was the steel to get
across well it's the same
we'll make steal these things that'll be
good
basically done let's get her over oh
god are you okay you okay
so what i've learned is steel
is just gooder and it costs just as much
for some reason it's exactly the same
price
which i've oh roadie steel is
right that road steel ah okay all right
never mind i'm dumb all right
so what we're gonna need to do is we're
gonna need to
build a straight line
from these two points of structure so
that we
can equidistantly
connect them into a point of pure
strength that's what i call
pure strength it's also over budget oh
god
okay maybe not
pure strength
you see what i'm going for there you see
that you see that
it's so strong there's also something
you can do
that's a little funky but i believe it
works when you have something
pulling down from the pressure
you can you can do like a cable so
effectively that helps hold it up but
obviously the suspension
is only as strong as you know
the angle that it's suspending from how
is that over budget
god this this hates me it hates me it
wants me to do
it a smart way with actually good sound
engineering principles and i'm just not
about that
i hope it understands that i am not
about actually
doing things right i'm about doing
things stupid
look at that look at that stable strong
strong stable ah
it's almost there it's almost perfect
look at this strong stable strong stable
strong stable strong stable stable
strong stable strong strong stable stuff
yeah we didn't need that anyway we
didn't need it we didn't need it we
didn't need it we know
you okay all right we almost made it
guys we almost made it look at that this
is strong and stable
strong and stable stable and strong even
stronger and even stabler
even stabler we don't need this one you
know what i'm going to get rid of it
because we don't need it
gotten rid of who needs it not us
[Laughter]
strong and stable strong and table
strong and stable strong and stable yes
and i'm under budget not bad that's a
pretty good bridge
it's a pretty good bridge not gonna say
any lies that's a pretty good bridge
despite some good nature bickering we
were making progress then we found a way
to put paid darrell back for the bike he
lost
only problem was a massive gap in the
road and all that all the walkers
hanging around
just so you all know we ain't leaving
without that rv i hear you now we just
need to find a way across what the hell
is that military thinking blowing up all
those bridges
taking it oh you know sometimes
even if an explosion looks cool it's not
always the best option but i can't think
of a single situation where it wouldn't
be the best option
other side seems to be crawling with
walkers anyone remember evel knievel
let's build us some ramps oh yeah no
one's gonna disagree with this idea this
is
this is just it okay so we gotta get
both of these over
oh you gonna be able to get enough speed
there pal
i don't like assuming this but let's
just assume that this is
how this is gonna go there's no way that
rv can get any kind of acceleration
going
okay and then sure we're gonna do like
this
bam that's strong and stable that's what
i call strong and stable
nope it's neither it's neither of those
things because you're not letting me
hang it
okay so they do get some speed so we
really don't need to do too much
okay ignore that cable there i know
there's probably a way to leverage
something so that we can have a dangling
down here and it pulls from up here but
that would require a lot of
different thinking that i'm not prepared
to do because thinking is not my
best ability i wonder if we could get
away with
a steel ramp here
and then wooden struts
well i mean obviously if there's no
support on the bottom that's never gonna
do anything
so this is a good base because it it
allows for the best
for the most stable support from this
structure and then this one also can
have
pretty good stability um across it
because it's being supported from the
top and the bottom
i technically don't need a steel here if
i could get away with a steel cable
there
i think it's just a best bet to have
this first
thing be steel because it just allows
for
a much better support system what i want
to avoid is to leverage things to twist
this
but given that this is a very strong
base
i mean in reality i could build things
to go down
and that would provide way more
stability because
of reasons you know what i mean
almost made it with just that not bad
not bad so the more like triangles i can
make
the better um just because
well this is a little one it's a little
unstable
yeah because i want to put the weight
down that's what has to happen
because otherwise you get things like
you know
that did stay okay almost almost okay i
wonder if i could do something
and i have an idea
does that hold not quite but if i
distribute the weight here additionally
nah still doesn't hold i'm not dumb i
swear i'm not pulling a eugene here
but i'm trying to channel his brain to
be able to solve this and it's really
like
starting to be detrimental
[Music]
okay i have a central pillar here
bam and it's gone but i've got a central
pillar here that
should function more as like
a strong stable base
with which to build off everything else
now the problem
when adding more weight here is that
it's going to start twisting this thing
and it's really just based on pure
compressive strength
there's a lot of compression strength
here but if it starts to torsion
it's not going to really do any good you
know what i mean
so what i have to do is figure out the
best way
to ensure that when i do build this
say you know like into some kind of a
rampish
thing that it's gonna maintain its
strength and not
buckle like a
ooh not gonna survive that oh it did it
did oh
god oh god no you almost made it okay
but we're on to something
we are in fact on to something
damn that overhang is a
it needs to be supported from the bottom
but in doing so i kind of compromise
the structure a bit but i can help
distribute the weight a little more
oh um
fascinating fascinating
[Music]
okay so that is enough for the car it's
not enough for the rv but that is enough
for the car and i've got
3567 to go for
or i've got about 1500 less than 1500 to
go for the bottom portion of it
so the bottom portion is aided by the
fact that it can be supported by
cables but only if those cables can
actually
support the weight which it looks like
they can
maybe
ah damn it okay so not quite okay so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna redesign
this to be
so
[Music]
oh oh almost oh oh
almost almost okay
well there's there's hope yet uh
maybe i have enough money for that yeah
oh
oh oh hey
[Music]
i did it oh my god i did it i did it
that certainly made a splash yeah only a
few deaths he had nothing about
knives would be proud oh that was fun
guys that was real fun
too much talking let's move on i agree
all right so that is gonna be it
ah that was a tough one but this is fun
like i i think it's it's
it's a nice twist to the game i mean i
don't know how they're going to get the
vehicle commands
in there with everything but you know
it's an interesting collab but i like it
honestly i just like the bridge
constructor games because i think
they're fun so if you want to play this
there's a link in the description below
that you can click on right there
uh check it out for yourself use create
a code markiplier and thank you to epic
games for sponsoring this video
and uh giving me actually a sponsor to
have so that's very fun
and uh this game is pretty cool so check
it out for yourself thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
bye